ich freue mich bald in die ferien zu
fliegen
ich freue mich dass ich bald in die
liga
ich freue mich dass sich bald in die
ferien fliegen
ich finde es bedenklich die tür nicht
abzuschließen
ich finde es bedenklich dass du die tür
nicht abschließt
bereust du mit deiner freundin schluss
gemacht zu haben
[Musik]
bereust du mit deiner freundin schluss
gemacht zu haben
ja ich bereue mit meiner freundin
schluss gemacht zu haben
ich bereue mit meiner freundin schluss
gemacht zu haben
nein ich bereue nicht dass ich mit
meiner freundin schluss gemacht habe
[Musik]
nein ich bereue nicht dass ich mit
meiner freundin schluss gemacht habe
er freut sich sein neues auto zu fahren
es ist mühsam die wäsche zu waschen
er findet es anstrengend bewerbungen zu
schreiben
es ist beruhigend die blumen zu gießen
es ist toll sich ball zu treffen es ist
toll dich bald zutreffen
es tut gut sport zu treiben
es ist wichtig immer fleißig zu lernen
es ist falsch betrunken auto
waren
es ist falsch betrunken auto zu fahren
es macht mir keinen spaß die wohnung zu
putzen
ich ärgere mich diesen fehler gemacht zu
haben
es langweilt mich tim lehrer zuzuhören
es langweilt mich dem lehrer zuzuhören
es kostet viel zeit die vokabeln
auswendig zu lernen
es kostet viel zeit die
abeln auswendig zu lernen
es stört mich immer lange warten zu
müssen
es stört mich immer lang
warten zu müssen
stört mich dass der bus verspätung hat
es stört mich dass der bus verspätung
hat es macht mir spaß mich zu verkleiden
[Musik]
das macht mir spaß mich zu verkleiden
es macht mir freude leute einzuladen
wozu gehst du zum friseur
[Musik]
ich gehe zum friseur um meine haare
schneiden zu lassen
[Musik]
ich gehe zum friseur damit er meine
haare schneidet ich gehe zum friseur
damit er meine haare schneidet ich gehe
zum friseur um hübsch auszusehen
ich gehe zum friseur um hübsch
auszusehen
wozu lernst du deutsch
wozu lernst du deutsch ich lerne deutsch
um an der universität zu studieren
ich lerne deutsch um an der universität
zu studieren
ich lerne deutsch um mit den menschen
sprechen zu können
ich lerne deutsch damit ich bessere
chancen für einen job habe ich lerne
deutsch damit ich bessere chancen für
einen job habe wozu trainierst du so oft
wozu trainierst du so oft ich trainiere
so oft um einen marathon zu laufen
[Applaus]
ich trainiere so oft um einen marathon
zu laufen
[Applaus]
ich trainiere so oft um gesund zu
bleiben
ich trainiere so oft damit ich viele
muskeln bekomme ich trainiere so oft
damit ich viele muskeln bekommen
lasst mich das mal
was mich das machen
es ist zu schwer für dich es ist zu
schwer für dich lass dich nicht
unterkriegen
lass dich nicht unterkriegen
das schaffst du schon dass
hast du schon wir lassen unsere wohnung
putzen
wir lassen unsere wohnung putzen der
gast lässt sich bedienen
der gast lässt sich bedienen
ich lasse mir von der friseur in die
haare schneiden
[Musik]
ich lasse mir von der friseur in die
haare schneiden
[Musik]
meine frau und ich lieben uns nicht mehr
wir lassen uns scheiden
entscheiden meine frau und ich haben uns
nicht mehr geliebt meine frau und ich
haben uns nicht mehr geliebt
wir haben uns scheiden lassen
wir haben
uns scheitern lassen
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video